this week conflict zone is in Vienna
where we caught up with Albania's Prime
Minister Eddie Rama was anxious to get a
move on with the whole process of
becoming a full GU member and warning of
dire consequences if his European dream
isn't realized but is he just looking to
get his hands on Europe's money
Eddie Rommel welcome to conflict zone
thank you thanks very much for being on
the program Albania is a candidate
member of the EU you're hoping for full
membership later on but you're showing a
lot of impatience with this and I'm
wondering why you said you weren't
coming to Vienna just for more photo
opportunities we have to see some
concrete results while it's pushing use
doing it the way it normally does it you
have the same criteria as everybody else
by the pressure no it's not about
avoiding to fulfil the criterias it's
about very simple difference between our
homework the criteria to be met and the
Berlin process which is a process of
regional cooperation so if we talk about
regional cooperation regional
infrastructure regional markets of
course we need to have a common strategy
and not only among ourselves but also
with Europe yeah but it's up to you as
much as its failure I mean why you why
are you pressing so hard why don't you
just wait your turn because I have to
tell you very frankly that if in Europe
there are people talking about
enlargement fatigue in the Balkans
Chancellor Merkel is not talking about
enlargement fatigue issue it's not even
Europe there are people I'm saying in
the Balkans there are more and more
people having a certain patience fatigue
so we need to move fast and to move
forward because I'm absolutely convinced
that Europe need the Balkans today as
much as the Balkans need Europe but I
want to ask you about that in a minute
but May 29th had you standing next to
Alexander vucic the Serbian Prime
Minister was saying we're fed up with
seminars we need some money from the EU
and then you'll see smiles on our faces
you didn't disagree with him as if
Europe has nothing else to do then just
sit there and give you money to put
smiles on your faces this is - this is
too reductive as a statement from your
side because first of all we are talking
about a common strategy because again I
want to say that the Balkans are Europe
and if the Balkans today are the only
success story
of peace and cooperation in our world
it's there is a reason and the reason is
because all of us we want to be part of
Europe and if the peace among Serbs and
Albanians happens and if for the first
time I visited a Belgrade after 68 years
as a being Prime Minister and voltage
came to Tirana as the first Prime
Minister from Serbia ever this shows
something of course shows our will but
shows first and foremost the aspiration
of our people but you Europe shown
plenty of goodwill to you I mean look at
the money that you've been offered
you've you've had funding allocations of
649 point four million euros for 2014 to
2020 European Bank for Reconstruction
and Development as offered you has 69
projects in Albania at the moment 917
million euros of investment and you're
pushing it the door and saying this
isn't enough we want more the numbers
are always a point of this of disputes
from my experiences published numbers in
case Germany has given you another
hundred and six million this this summer
I know the electricity sector but again
I'm saying to you numbers may mislead
and again we are not talking about money
for our national interests or for our
national budget we are talking about
much more money for our regional
infrastructure for our regional projects
because no one of our countries can
afford to pay these regional projects
with its own money you should you should
know that we are physically we don't
tell anymore fiscal space we can't give
sovereign guarantees so we need to work
together in that so and let me give you
an example but these figures are working
together
this is the investment that you need to
carry out the reforms that Europe has
asked you to do to become members of the
EU and we are carrying out the reforms
that Europe has asked us to do with a
lot of will with a lot of speed it will
take time and again we don't we are not
trying to replace the homework and the
integration process of every country by
this but we are saying that the regional
cooperation process has to work and has
and to make it work need to be financed
and hanging over all this is the threat
you made in May you told the Turkish
hariette newspaper as long as our
European dream is vivid the Balkans will
have no trouble but if this dream fades
away trouble will come in other words
give us what we want or will cause
trouble not it's not like that's right
isn't it it's not a threat is pretty
much like it sounds wrong it's not a
threat is a very simple truth because in
the Balkans we came out of a long
history of bloodshed wars conflict and
so on so the ghosts of the past around
or our generation will make it in the
right way and we'll all unify with
Europe and it will be over or the ghosts
of the past will take over so it's a
reserve now to referee your squabbles
for you and your views and your ancient
hatreds you're laying it all at Europe's
door now
it sounds very much like Tory statement
but I'm not I'm not at all saying that
I'm repeating Europe should be strategic
about the Balkans it's not business as
usual
either is an area that you know very
well has been a big problem for the
people living in the area
and for the continent for centuries now
it's an area that is in a fantastic
new moment of peace and cooperation but
this piece is too big for our shoulders
but I mean it's nimble to be fed with a
common common effort and of course I
understand the common effort but let's
talk about this fantastic moment for a
moment because you said in April you
repeated a threat to unify with costs
are not thrilled without the EU these
are not threats right you said you would
unify with Kosovo either without I will
you no no it's not accurate I said we
want to unify with Europe and be
together in European Union and Europe
should be strategic about this otherwise
forces all past can make it in a
different way what you actually said
April the six and this was an interview
with clan Kosova yes the radio station
the question is how it will happen this
unification in the context of the EU as
a natural process understood by all or
will it happen as a reaction to EU
blindness or laziness so you're already
accusing me your blindness and lazy I am
I'm not accusing I'm just I'm simply
stating stating the obvious be you
didn't like that statement very much
accused you of provocations unacceptable
provocation the Serbs didn't like it I
think that's why we want to be in the
you
we don't need necessity to like
everything everyone says otherwise you
do you know why stirring it up are they
saying we we had the communism where we
were supposed to like everything was
said to not contest anything so it's
intentionally what you knew exactly
which buttons to press with the Serbs
didn't you know what you had to do was
mention unification with your smile says
it all all you had to do was my smack
about my unification with Kosovo and
they would accuse you of banging the
drums of war which is exactly what they
did and do that and they were wrong
because I was entering a drum I was
simply saying the obvious we have not
got rid of the ghost all paths and who
ever think that Balkans now is once and
forever in peace and this is for granted
is wrong so you know my point is you
like to stir up these ghosts maybe I
want I sure I won't give you an egg
always sure that you don't forget that
the ghosts are around and we should work
together to make sure that they will not
come in the scene again because if they
come in scene their troubles not only
for hospitals for you
okay so spell out what are these
troubles then are you talking about
going back to war no I'm talking about
these troubles and if you don't get you
you I'm talking about all the terrible
things that nationalisms and hatred
bring with it and we know it very well
let's spell it out what what what is it
what is it what is that in the past I
asked you whether it was war you said no
no no I'm saying war has come in the
worst can happen and this is why we have
to boost this peace process of
cooperation and of interaction and we
cannot do it alone
we need to do it with Europe because the
European process is not just every
nation process ok so breaking your
argument down to its component parts if
we don't get what we want we don't get
all your dream we're going to war oh no
that's exactly not just oh no no no no
no I'm saying that if Europe will not
realize that cannot treat the Balkans as
business as usual we risk to be
overcomes again by the ghosts of the
past ok say you get your EU membership
full EU membership the other candidate
members it will take that and the other
candidate members get it and there you
are you're sitting in Brussels and you
suddenly think to yourself ok well these
other members of the the Balkans they're
getting more out of this than we are so
you start the feud with in Europe are
gone you start quarreling you can with
in Europe you're gonna bring the whole
project crashing down you can do better
than that
we're can you do better than that we are
you do better this is a question we are
not supposed now to speculate what will
happen when we sit in the European Union
together with our neighbors we are
supposed today to do everything we can
to work with our neighbors and to make
possible that the dreams of our young
generation end of our youth become true
finally we need to have the Balkans as
part of the European Union and we are
working for that and we are seeing the
benefits of working for that as far as
Europe is concerned what you're doing is
just handing the job of refereeing
between you and other Balkan states to
Brussels and why should Brussels be
burdened with that I don't think I don't
think first that Europe is thinking that
there are people in Europe thinking that
first second what is Brussels for that's
not to manage your disputes we are know
that we have already managed our
disputes we don't have disputes we are
now together in the same line with the
same voice saying now we another say
change our already to do it
all those hatreds all those ghosts have
gone away one moment you say they've all
gone away and then they're just waiting
to wake up the girls are not gone away
the Glaus are not in the scene today
because the scene thanks to all this
will has is occupied now by the people
that have made peace and want to
cooperate together the EU has asked you
for progress on many different fronts
reforms area is still causing major
concern as far as the last progress
report is concerned from the EU
Commission organized crime Albania still
lacks a comprehensive overall strategic
approach to organized crime this is a on
earth-2 you lack it is an approach to
that strategic after all this time this
is December it's not rubber last year
this is October last year true and in
the same time we should not forget that
exactly because we fault
hardly against organized crime and with
facts we got the candidates items but
it's an and I am very happy I hope that
you are very happy to inform you that
from January to now this year we have
lowest criminal crime rate in the
country since 25 years so that's not
saying much it's not saying a lot isn't
it's saying a lot because your crime has
been huge and remains huge relative to
other states I'm not sure now I'm not
sure numbers are not saying that you
like numbers I'll come to numbers in a
minute on the rights of women the number
of reported serious offences cases of
domestic violence against women
increased according to the report last
year why yes there we have a problem
with domestic violence and we are
tackling it and I'm very happy to tell
you that in the last local election we
made sure something that make us one of
the champions in fighting for women
rights and for women representation in
Europe 50% of every City Council in
Albania today are women and this is a
big achievement of course why the
violence is equal to do we have to fight
against it is something that has not
been born in the last years is something
that has to do with a very patriarchal
and also with a very very painful past
and we are fighting against in a very
improving okay deep reform of the
judiciary is urgently needed is the in
autumn in autumn we will pass this
reform thanks to a very very thorough
work we have done together with European
missions with Venice Commission with the
American mission of experts so the
reform will be very radical and there
will be the right base to start and
change it because I fully agree with you
that we have really a big fight in this
field and judiciary is our opening
and I've always told my fellow citizens
if we will not be able to have a
judiciary that will dignify our country
will never be able to be part of the
European Union and you've still got a
long way to go absolutely on crime
Albania is a source and destination
country for men women and children
subjected to sex trafficking and forced
on on on this on this area we have made
a big improvement because we have been
out of the blacklist
and now of course there is still a lot
to do but we have made a big jump what
do you mean your answer the blacklist
because before we were we were a country
that was a country of origin and a
country that was among the countries
that were really in a kind of blacklist
Europe our report 2013 spoke of the
danger of weapons trafficking through
your region organised crime groups
including Albanians under dominate yes
dominate the trafficking in you in
heroin 2013 is the geological a year ago
frankly because the changes are too fast
oh and your crime groups have all taken
up sheep farming since then have they no
I'm no because we have eradicated and
with a big price for our European
fellows this safe have enough shame in
Lazar at where these big plantations
were and you talk about cannabis about
cannabis and so we ever educated it okay
so how many mafia leaders have you taken
off the streets
how many mafia leaders mafia leaders
yeah how many of you have you jailed we
don't have muffin leaders in lumbini and
my fellows are in Europe oh really so
you have no organized crime we have so
when you think about Europe says Albania
is a source and destination country for
trafficking you don't have any criminal
we talked about mafia leaders the mafia
leaders are on the other side of
Adriatic we have the we have our
organized crime which is connected and
let's not talk anymore about a national
mafia there is no national mafia there
is no there is no organized crime person
you you keep you you catch that does not
have three four five different codes in
the mobile phone so it's interconnected
how many judges have you fired one as
far as I can see god forbid if the
government would fire judges would be in
trouble it's not the government that
fires judges it's and that's why we're
making before you have corrupt judges we
don't have corrupt judges we have a
totally corrupt judiciary which works
like a corporation and which works like
for-profit industry and we are breaking
it down starting from this reform that
will pass in fall let me ask you about
some of the allegations that have come
your way on August the 12th a opposition
leader losing basha accused you of
publicly dealing with organized crime
you said your government is deeply
connected to crime you're not saying
anything about these accusations we live
in a civilization that sees long time as
has a principle it's up to the user to
prove the accusation and not to be
accused to prove that he is not guilty
if I'd be answering all the time to the
allegations I would not have time to do
anything else
even to eat so why did they Supreme
Court order the prosecutor to
investigate your other allegations that
you gave illegal building permits to
companies when you were mayor of Tirana
this is not true this procedure what do
you mean it's procedure procedural but
it's not true in the sense that it's a
procedure that is has to be respected
and that's it if it's not true why and
you have all these accusations why don't
you sue the people who are making these
accusations against if you if you I did
it are innocent I did it I did it losing
Basha 12th of August his latest
accusations why don't you sue it's not
as well
I if I would sue for every accusation I
would stay in front of the Supreme Court
every morning but I have tried also the
way of suing and just to give an example
to two people and I want it for good
they were not able to prove anything of
what they said and at the end they said
something fantastic politics is not to
give proofs if is to make happen sound
opinions so these are sound opinions I
don't care you formed a coalition with a
man could Ilya Metta about whom you said
two years before in 2011 he exemplified
all that was rotten about Albania yes
yeah I said you said it and you were so
keen so desperate for power that you
would get into bed politically with a
man who you clearly despised all right
it's not I strongly believe that it's
not about men it's not about people it's
about systems so when you did is attack
the system attack but it's not you
attacked the man well I mean it's not
about men it's not about people it's
about systems and I have I was not
desperate for power
I was desperate to see Albania move
forward and to do everything I can to
make it happen and I'm doing it happen
together with the others and I'm very
happy to see it
so so you haven't changed your mind
about how rotten he is this man again
it's not about man and well you made it
about ie so you made it eyes I said it
it was and you made it about him 2011
you say those 2011 okay I said it yeah
so now I'm saying to you that we have a
coalition this is very well functioning
and we're doing a great job together
how many rotten people do you have these
days in your governing coalition we
don't have rotten people no no wrinkles
except for the person that you called
rotten in 2011 I did again
and I repeat I'm not denying it but
there is something very simple about
politics it functions through elections
it functions through numbers and it
functions through programs and common
agenda so as far as all this is in place
things can move forward and buying a
vote still happens in your elections
transparency international said in 2013
all parties bought votes especially in
albania's villages and suburbs no voters
paid 35 euros for a vote the the if I
would say to you that there is no any
votes boat in Albania outlie but in the
same time I can say very truthfully that
all these numbers and all this
generation a generation way of talking
is very harmful is not respecting the
truth yeah but it still happens the
American ambassador said before their
local elections there were people
standing who had criminal records
founded that there were people with
criminal records that was that were out
of than out of the race and there were
people that wrongly were considered
criminals without having had any kind of
process that have made them declare
criminal so we live in a society and we
live in a system where there are
separated powers and where no one has
right to say that he is criminal or
she's criminal it's only the persecution
and the judiciary that case against
Eddie Brahma given all the problems that
we've discussed given all the issues the
urgent need to reform various sectors I
understand what's in it for you to join
Europe what's in it for Europe to have
you with all your problems
with all your ghosts come on May wake up
any it's not it's not it's not it
doesn't work that way
Europe will have only benefits to get
the Balkans in get meals
come on I give you one because the
Balkans are not somewhere are in the
middle of Europe and so Europe has no
has no logic to leave this area in the
heart of it out of its own way of
functioning and of being organized
because then if what day is dream will
be replaced by nightmare it will be
European nightmare it will not be as
simple simply an Albanian or a Serb or a
Balkan nightmare Hedy Rama thanks for
dinner conflict so thank you very much
there's an honor
Oh